-Thank you for being here.
I appreciate you being here.
Your family came with you
on this trip to New York.
-Of course they did.
-Yeah, which I do love.
You know who's stealing
the show, though?
It's -- It's granny.
-It's Granzo Pat.
-Granny Pat, I'm in love with.
-Everyone is.
Everyone treats her
like a princess, and she's like,
"I'm here."
[ Laughter ]
-But -- does she --
Here's a picture of you
and Granny on the red carpet.
-No!
-No, come on.
Yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Yeah.
-How is she loving
her newfound fame?
-You know what?
She actually
got her first gifting.
-First what?
-Gifting.
Like, she's now so famous that
people are gifting her things.
[ Laughter ]
And I went to Ireland,
and someone came and gave her a
gift, and when she received it,
months later, she goes,
"You must -- You must give me
the address of that person."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Which person
are you talking about?"
And she goes, "The person that
gave me that beautiful handbag.
I need to write her
a thank-you note."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-See, that's exactly right.
-And I was like, "Granny,
I have no clue who that is."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
No one even does that --
Good for Granny Pat.
I love her.
-I know, but she's gonna
wear it, at some point, and show
that she's very thankful.
-And how does she get, like --
does she --
does she mingle
with other celebrities?
-I don't know.
Oh, yeah, no, no, actually, no.
One time, at Venice, she kept on
going up to Chris Pine and --
[ Laughter ]
She kept on going up
and being like,
"I'm more famous than you."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-I know.
-That's the best.
-Yeah.
-I saw you at the Oscars.
You were fantastic.
Again, here's -- this is --
this is what a movie star
looks like right there.
-Aww.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our buddy Andrew Garfield.
And the Internet went wild,
by the way.
They were like, "Those two
should do a movie together."
-You know what's crazy is, we --
They didn't know that we were
doing a movie together.
Well, I don't think they did,
but this was, I think,
a bit of an accident.
-Yeah.
-Which is even weirder --
-They just thought you guys
would have good chemistry
together.
-Yeah, they put us together,
and then...
-You are doing a --
-We are doing a movie together.
Don't worry. That's not a lie.
We are doing a movie together.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And -- I --
I met him the day before
in rehearsals,
and we instantly got along,
and I was takin' the piss out
of him, and he loved it.
And he was takin' the piss out
of me, and I loved it.
It was great.
-Yeah.
That's what it's all about.
I want -- I want to talk about
your new movie, okay?
"A Good Person."
-Yes.
-This is written and directed
by Zach Braff.
-Yes.
-Who I love.
He's a great guy.
So talented,
but also super funny.
-Yeah, let's give him applause.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, love Zach Braff.
I like that guy.
-Yes.
He told me to have fun tonight,
and as he texted,
"Tell mommy I love him."
[ Laughter ]
And it was a typo
and actually was "Jimmy."
[ Laughter ]
-I was gonna say, I was like,
I don't know if he --
I was like,
"Did he ever call me mommy?
That's cool."
-But I love -- I love the fact
that "Tell mommy I love him."
-Yeah, tell -- tell --
-Tell mommy you love him, too.
-Tell him mommy loves him
so much.
Mommy loves you, Zach!
[ Laughter ]
But he --
he wrote this film for you.
-He did.
He wrote it for me.
-You were his muse. I mean --
-I was his muse.
I think, also, there's like --
there's so much ease
with reading a script when
someone knows how you talk
and how far they can, like,
push you
and what
you're capable of doing.
So it was just a joy.
-Yeah.
-It was so much fun.
-And I got to say, also,
I love Molly Shannon.
Who doesn't love Molly Shannon?
But she's in the film, as well.
-She is.
She plays my mother.
Molly Shannon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How was Molly?
Just fun, right?
-Unbelievable.
So funny.
So amazing to work with.
We have this epic scene
where we, like -- we --
we chase each other --
Well, I run away from her,
and she's chasing after me,
and it gets into
quite a bit of a tussle.
And halfway through fighting --
like, doing the scene,
we had to pause because it was
getting quite aggressive,
and instead of us, like,
maybe not fighting as hard,
she was like,
"Let's put some pads on."
[ Laughter ]
And that --
that was the approach.
It was like,
"Instead of not actually
beating each other up,
let's put pads on
so we can go harder."
-Really go harder.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That is so Molly, right?
-Yeah.
-That's perfect.
You also get to --
You wrote and you get to sing
in this movie.
-I do, yeah.
-And what a lovely voice
you have.
And it's --
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I want to --
I'd love to see more.
I want to hear more.
-Well, what's cool is --
is it's the first time
I've actually written a song
for a character and performed a
song as the character, as well.
So that was really nice.
But then outside of the movie,
I got to record them
as how I would like them, as me,
as, like, the creator.
So when the movie comes out,
my songs are gonna be
on the soundtrack, as well.
So have a little --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you get --
Do you get nervous?
'Cause, obviously, we know you
can act, but you're like --
Singing is kind of
a private thing you do,
like, in your house.
And you're -- I'm not sure --
in front of people.
-Yeah.
I think -- well, for years,
I was always always more
of a singer-songwriter.
It was happening more when I was
younger, singer-songwriting,
than it was acting.
And then when I did first gig
as an actor,
it just took off in that way.
And so I hadn't done it
in a long while.
So, yeah, there's a bit
of confidence-building,
but I'm really excited to do it.
I've been wanting to do it
for ages.
-Yeah, oh, crusher.
That's great.
In the movie, your character
cuts her own hair.
-Yeah.
-And I heard that you
actually said,
"I'll cut my own hair."
-It was my idea.
I was like, "Zach, I think
I should chop my hair off
at the beginning of the movie."
And he was like...
-The beginning of the movie.
-..."Cool.
That's not gonna work."
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"We have the whole movie shoot."
-Yeah, initially, it was that --
it was -- but how do we
do the shooting in order?
And I was like,
"You'll figure it out."
[ Laughter ]
-"You'll figure it out?"
-Yeah, and then
they got together,
and they all had
big conversations.
And they were like,
"Zach, this is insane.
She can't do this.
This is not helpful at all."
So he came and spoke to me,
very, like, tentatively
and was like, "Florence,
we can't do this.
We're gonna need to use a wig."
-"We'll use a wig."
-"You'll figure it out.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And they figured it out!
-Yeah, you said, "You're gonna
have to figure it out,"
'cause you did it.
-I did it!
-You cut your own hair.
-That was --
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah, beautiful job.
-So the point is, it's supposed
to be a bit shabby,
but, obviously, in between,
like, we were shooting,
we were trying to shoot all
of it in -- in the one take.
We couldn't --
we had to change the setup.
-Yeah.
-And so there was one portion
for about half an hour where I
had one really long strand
of hair down to my hip,
and then the rest of it was
this short, like a unicorn.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's like
the ultimate mullet.
-And --
[ Laughter ]
Can we say what
the movie's about to kind of
explains why you would
cut your own hair?
-Yes, why I'm doing that.
Sorry, guys.
It is about --
It's about addiction.
It's about grief.
It's about guilt.
It's about the opioid crisis.
And in fantastic Zach Braff
fashion, he finds
moments of lightness in,
you know,
many stories of darkness.
And so we've created a movie
that hopefully will affect
the right people and maybe some
others, too, along the way.
But, yeah, we find my character,
Allison, on this really
tricky and tough journey about
recovery and about addiction.
And I get to hang out with
Morgan Freeman
and Molly Shannon.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, ooh!
-It's really great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show a clip.
Here's Florence Pugh
in "A Good Person."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Hi.
I'm here to get
a prescription refilled.
Last name, Johnson.
Birthday, August 24th.
-Okay.
For which medication?
-Uh, the oxy.
Oxycontin.
-It says here
you are out of refills.
I see you've been on them
for over a year now.
Your doctor is probably trying
to wean you off of them.
As I'm sure you know,
they can be very addictive.
-Oh, really?
I hadn't [bleep] heard that.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Florence Pugh, everyone!
You got to see it.
"A Good Person"
is in theaters this Friday.
Florence and I are playing
a fun game when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.